maïté était employé la sncf où elle
jouer du clairon sur la voie ferrée pour
annoncer l'arrivée des trains un jour
comme dans un conte de fées elle fait la
rencontre d'un réalisateur de télévision
qui éblouit découvre ses talents de
cuisinière depuis elle mitonne
régulièrement des plats devant la caméra
et de tuteurs à la sncf elle est devenue
une star des médias
tabiou
et notre ami joly
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
maïté impératrice de la cuisine sur une
autre chaîne et pierre trois stars maïté
ordonez a donc fait le voyage avec
micheline voyage aurions les landes
paris pour répondre à l'invitation de
télé dimanche à leur maïté
les olympiques
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors j'ai quitté l'école à 14 ans quand
vous entends je pense j'ai travaillé
chez lui et il fallut des revélois de
celle utilisée de se brûler je suis
partisan à paris et en souviennent bon
on a fait un niveau intellectuel
extraordinaire après de paris ii survenu
je me suis marié les pierrots il m'a
faire il m'a fait serge le rappeler
après je suis allé
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait après après je
suis rentré cncf 23e cf
entre temps j'ai rencontré patrice ça
fait dix ans j'ai commencé la télévision
ensuite j'ai eu la chance de prendre le
restaurant il va ou pas la maréchaussée
et la télé et me voilà avec vos autres
maintenant aujourd'hui tout cas
l'assiette c'est pour ça
[Musique]
patrice bello on sait pas trop si vous
êtes réalisateur ou cuisine je suis un
aléa ambulant c'est au cours d'un film
que je faisais sur l'histoire du rugby
en france au cours d'une troisième
mi-temps assez agitée que j'ai rencontré
mme aït el car la fin de ce repas où il
avait une centaine de personnes
j'ai vu arriver une personnes chantant
la dacquoise entouré de d d d autres
femmes bénévoles de rion des landes qui
servait ce repas et j'ai eu le tout d'un
coup le déclic en disant mais c'est la
cuisinière que l'on cherche pour la
série que nous avons en projet et nous
n'avions pas trouvé la personne qui
correspondait à ce que vous souhaitiez
[Musique]
oui au caire damas ajoute à la tension
n'aime pas beaucoup les talents et les
arénas et très peu plus un couac euros
la semoy je pèse mes ailes belle carmen
1100 kg et moi c'est ma première fois
que nous en mer ce alors embuscade car
il allait de toute façon c'est très
gentil très loose et alors el assad
je fais revenir mais noah emma verdure
dans quoi d'art et celle de canard comme
moi tout simplement
c'est un mytho deux pays
[Musique]
mais les noix tu touil il rajoute les
anchois citrouille mon horaire tu
rajoutes de la verdure
oui c'est à dire le romarin les ai
battus tous y le cresson est là et là
vous ne parlez plus pas son fromage et
jeux sonneries rien que la viande de
cette eau est quand même un navire ne
serait faire douter
patrice parlez-moi de maïté il y a
tellement de choses à dire sur ces
femmes dont la vie s'est transformée qui
vit un conte de fées actuellement non je
dirais une seule chose c'est que je suis
vraiment très content car la télévision
est un peu le miroir aux alouettes
beaucoup beaucoup se brûle les ailes
comme des papillons et je crois que
maïté doit beaucoup à la télévision
c'est le contraire
et tant mieux
fleuret d'or des mousquetaires à l'heure
actuelle ne parle du marché l'audience
démission ne cesse d'augmenter ce qui
est merveilleux première place pour les
baskets et piperade le 28 janvier 1993
avec 15 7% de la part du marché aux
veaux et les câbles deuxième place
fricassée de poisson au sauternes le 19
janvier 1993 avec 13 9 % de la part du
marché
sa baisse un peu mais c'est pas mal la
cuisine des mousquetaires pour moi c'est
l'accusé des miracles parce que c'est un
miracle aux grandes écoles de mois qu'il
était rien rien rien rien jeter une
ouvrière
j'étais d'une femme comme tout le monde
mais moment que tout le monde parce que
je n'avais rien personne ne regarde et
personne ne faisait attention mon
rigoler on s'amusait mais personne
maintenant tout le monde des cousins
tout le monde et a mis tout le monde a
fait les hautes études avec moi tout le
monde en leur volant à je viens de la
part d' et l'a été à l'école avec vous
j'étais à l'école primaire - dario c'est
toutes les études que j'ai fait
alors les autres études elle a subjugué
jamais été et on a fait pas mal de temps
ça fait rire et moi moi je ne connais
que les gens que j'ai toujours connu et
les gens que je n'ai pu qui se veulent
pas rares amis maintenant je les connais
pas plus parce que j'ai jamais connu
avant ils sont jamais fait connaître
avant et maintenant moi je ne connais
pas davantage mangent reste avec ce que
j'ai toujours connu jusque là
je fais de la télévision comme j'ai des
coups fourrés moi j'ai eu une enfance
très heureuse qu'on s'entendait très
bien entre frères et soeurs et puis nous
avons évidemment papa une maman qui
était cultivateur et résignés on était
très heureux parce que le matin avant
d'aller à l'école j'allais l'amour et
c'est à dire jaillit des émules et je
partais à l'école mais ça m'arrivait de
faire l'école buissonnière aussi quand
même être parce qu'on partait car une
bonne quinzaine à l'école et on revenait
pratiquement tous ensemble donc c'était
un jeu extraordinaire
et quand on rentre et on était toujours
avec nos parents il n'y avait pas la
télévision il mon père me disait tu ne
sauras jamais rien tu ne feras jamais
lienne teddy toi tu ne sortira jamais de
riom tu ne pourras pas écrire à ton
fiancé tu ne pourras pas sortir on
l'aliment prométhée c'est terrible et il
a cru bon lui là il a pas connu du tour
du tout la télé yacouba maire qui a
connu un petit peu au des atouts débuts
il ya dix ans dans les trois premières
années
et qu'est ce qu'elle est heureuse et
quand c'est de pouvoir mouvoir la télé
parce que je me disais énormément c'est
ce serait il le voit d'avoir une eau
voirie
mon mari lui quand par la vie des autres
j'ai beaucoup de qualités mais moi il me
dit tout que je fais tout va mais si
jamais vous vous avez le malheur de me
critiquer vous
il fallait que mon mari s'y fasse un
petit peu parce que c'est quand même un
changement extraordinaire et on est
parent fait ni l'un ni l'autre opposé
georges de beauce au gérant de vie parce
que chacun son truc mais ça c'est se
passer du coq à l'âne comment dire
on est vraiment passer du coq là le long
l'un
[Musique]
mutine c'est une femme d'une rare
intelligence vous lui dites heures mon
élan fait un livre et ensuite qu'on peut
très bien ça fait laurel et hardy
micheline et moi parce que mich témoin
je fais pour moi j'arrive par j'attaque
et puis elle est la riche elle m'a
freiné le mal raconté les voilà et alors
elle comme on dit elle fait la bête pour
me faire parler pour faire bien
expliquer alors que tout le monde croit
que mon dieu pourquoi la pose des
questions mais devait pas du tout c'est
celui qui pose qui disait qu'il ne
comprend rien
elle me pose des questions bêtes pour
que moi je puisse c'est moi la bête pour
que j'ai pu s'expliquer et comment ça se
passe notre recette traditionnelle
notre recette c'en est terminé oui
presque
vous avez donné qu'il y du marais bien
sûr notre superbe blonde d'aquitaine ne
peut être pas rejoint de ses soins mais
il est bon de ne pas peindre les
traditions il faut savoir les conserver
il faut tendre retrouver ce jeu wii ne
soit fait plaisir même voilà alors
amusez vous avec de supers de viande que
vous ferez simplement sur le gris dans
votre cheminée ou un soir d'hiver sans
cheminée avec un petit mélange de ce
genre qui vous a rappellera vos ancêtres
peut-être au revoir bientôt merci d'être
resté avec nous bon appétit
merci
c'est pas terrible
il est pas content c'est pas vrai quand
j'ai vu puis est pas mal et je crois
qu'on veut boire s'amuser moi je peux
pas travailler s'ils ne m'amuse pas
c'est un premier point ensuite y en a eu
d'eau parce qu'elle nous a raconté plein
d'histoires d'abord il m'a dit qu'elle
jouait de la musique qu'elle était
musicienne qui tire c'est drôle vol
physique d'une grande violoniste
français jamais et puis elle m'a dit
donc mais travailler sur les voies avec
sa trompette
elle avait les horaires la montre devait
surveiller les horaires et ce n'est de
la trompette contraint arrivé et il m'a
dit un jour le travail et près d'une
courbe
je savais que je n'entendrai pas le
train arrivait donc il fallait faire
très attention à l'heure pour prévenir
les ouvriers malheureusement mon oeil
tout elle peut glisser vers la revoir
qu'est-ce que j'ai eu deux escargots
et j'étais tellement intrigué que j'ai
oublié l'heure j'ai oublié tous et
toutes à couvrot mlle train d'arriver
nous avons tous sauté dans les prés
personne n'est mort et tout s'est bien
terminé j'ai dit comment ce que les
escargots ont terminé leur amour ça elle
sert plus mais je me suis dit on va
s'amuser avec des histoires comme ça on
va s'amuser et on s'amuse depuis 10
c'est merveilleux dans la vie
[Musique]
parfait
regardez nos émissions et puis aussi nos
cassettes
voilà vous avez là une autre adresse
mais quand tu y seras sûrement 500-600
francis hallé très très pudique elle ne
se confie pas si elle est malade si elle
est fatiguée on ne me le diras pas je ne
le saurai que dix quinze jours après un
mois après elle m'a fait des petites
alertes de santé physique que je ne les
ai apprises que un mois après parce
qu'elle me les cachent nos rapports sont
très affectueux mais ne veut pas manquer
c'est l'angoissé
oui oui bon combien de personnes 20
personnes ce serait beau car oui regarde
bien sûr de vos vidéos peut les prendre
non c'est complet le relais des landes
c'est un rêve ça aussi et puis là c'est
pareil je suis arrivée là on n'y
connaissez rien rien du tout en rien il
y avait comme un ami et c'est notre avis
qui a fait l'école hôtelière et là on
est on a démarré on a fait comme on a pu
et mon personnel et merveilleux parce
que j'aime personnel c'est tous des
neveux et nièces il travaillait avec moi
mon frère me faire la comptabilité c'est
tout baigné à ceux qui servent et je ne
les commente jamais je ne dis jamais le
travail qu'il faut qu'elle fasse tous
avaient tous dit que j'ai un coup dur
dès que je suis malade ou qu'il ya
beaucoup de monde qui a fait perdre tout
le monde arrive à mes frères mes soeurs
des amis et je n'ai qu'à lever le petit
doigt tout le monde est là
je peux compter sur eux il aurait été
élevée comme moi et il ya un proverbe
qui dit aidez vous les uns les autres et
non c'est de beaucoup c'est cette
nouvelle vie qui donne le vertige parce
que avant un moment j'arrive et je
j'arrivais j'étais quand même je faisais
mon petit train chez moi j'allais où
j'avais envie j'avais chez ma belle-mère
j'allais chez ma mère j'allais chez ma
table de jeu faisait beau petit tout
mais c'est tout mais là il faut aller
partout il faut penser à tout il faut
être partout à la fois et le personnel
et la télé et commander tout et
olalalala ces terribles par tête qui
dans ma jeunesse et n'a jamais travaillé
et c'est maintenant qu'il faut que je la
fasse travailler un petit peu dingue en
servant ici
il a évolué light obligé
[Musique]
le parrot quasi leur tour d'argent et
jamais je serai à l'heure parce que j'ai
de très rares y avait 15 ans par midi
car je n'ai rien de près rien du tout
alors je pourrais je être la plus
élégante je crois que je vais faire
comme les femmes de crise dure je
pourrais mettre ce soit et puis comme ça
je serai habillé plaisir ce soir canal +
la tour d'argent
c'est un rêve
[Musique]